So as we're going to talk about a little bit
later today, Donald Trump left Washington,
D.C. yesterday after vetoing the
second coronavirus relief bill and
appears to be turning on absolutely everyone
around him, including Vice President Mike Pence.
And things are going to get interesting for
these last few weeks based on a report from Axios
Jonathan Swan. It appears that the reason Trump is
turning on everybody is fury and rage, that others
are not indulging Trump's conspiracy theories
about the election, nor his absolutely hopeless
and absurd ideas for how to overturn the results.
Donald Trump has reportedly been outraged at
Vice President Mike Pence at Chief of Staff, Mark
Meadows at White House, Counsel Patrick Maloney at
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo, and even at Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell. And even though
once again, the White House and the people
around Trump have distanced themselves from
attorney Sydney Powell, it appears as though it's
her perspective. That's the one that is in Trump's
mind primarily, which is that everybody around him
who's not willing to foment his harebrained ideas
for how to overturn the election are seen by
Trump as being weak, stupid or disloyal or some
combination of the three. And the effect of this,
again, according to Jonathan Suan from Axios,
is that the few people around Trump with an iota
of common sense are reportedly very concerned
about Donald Trump's behavior. Donald Trump
reportedly thinks Mike Pence isn't fighting
hard enough for him. Donald Trump is furious
that White House Counsel Patrick Polony isn't
doing enough of the things Trump wants to try to
overturn the election. Trump thinks anyone who's
not willing to push for the Department of Justice
to forcibly I'm sorry, the it's not justice. It's
Homeland Security to forcibly seize voting
machines. Anybody who doesn't want that is weak.
And apparently it's not just Trump cultists and
loyalists who are looking at January 6th as an
important date, because according to people who
have discussed January 6th with Donald Trump, he
is also apparently thinking that maybe Mike Pence
can do something for him as he oversees the formal
counting of the electoral vote. Donald Trump spoke
Monday night with Republicans in the House about
voting to overturn the results on January 6th,
which is just completely absurd. And then lastly,
it does appear that Donald Trump has also fully
turned on Senate Majority Leader, Republican
Senator Mitch McConnell, including listen to
this, Trump had his own personal assistant email
Republican lawmakers on Monday night, a single
PowerPoint slide that attacks Mitch McConnell.
So there's every indication that the last couple
of weeks of this administration, after we get back
from from the New Year's break, are going to be
completely and utterly insane. The grifters and
the conspiracy theories really seem to have gotten
to Donald Trump. And Trump actually seems to have
fallen for all of the craziest ideas and the most
laughable notions about this election and about
how he could potentially overturn the results and
get a second term, none of which will work, but
will embarrass him and really damage the country
if he continues to try. And so if the last few
weeks are evidence of anything, they're evidence
that that 25th Amendment to remove a president
would never have been more appropriate than it is
right now. But it's not even worth talking about
more. It's just not going to happen. The themes
here are Trump can never accept responsibility.
He can never accept losing. Everything is always
somebody else's fault. He can never accept
that his actions have consequences. He sees the
consequences, but he doesn't connect them to his
past actions. He he blames other people. And by
the time we get back early in twenty, twenty one,
there's sort of two paths here. Donald Trump
will either have continued escalating from this
to something even more outrageous or he won't come
back to the White House at all after his Christmas
trip to Florida. And he'll just sort of evaporate
the way he's been behaving the last 48 hours.
Makes me think he's not going to go quietly. But
all we can do is wait and see. But Republicans
are increasingly worried about his behavior.
And I want to talk about that next time.